Hi, my name is Carl and I am a Software Engineer
on the Google Chrome team. In this video,
I will describe how to integrate with the
Chrome Web Store Licensing API.
Suppose you are creating a web app. The Chrome
Web Store makes it easy to charge people to
use that app wherever it is running. Users
will purchase access to your app right from
the Chrome Web Store. To check whether a user
has paid for your app, use the Chrome Web
Store’s licensing API.
The licensing API takes two inputs: the app
ID and the user ID.
The app ID is the id the Chrome Web Store
assigns to your app when you first create
it in the store.
The user ID is the Google-provided OpenID
URL. Typically, with OpenID the user ID is
not shared unless the user explicitly grants
permission to the application; however, Google
Chrome grants this permission automatically
when the user installs the application. Users
in other browsers will still see an approval
step.
A number of OpenID libraries may be used to
determine the OpenID URL.
To see a comprehensive list of libraries just
visit http://wiki.openid.net/Libraries.
Some specific OpenID libraries you can explore
are the following:
For Java you can try OpenID4Java.
For Python try using Google App Engine’s
Django OpenID.
You can find more information on how to use
OpenID in our documentation.
The Chrome Web Store doesn’t allow just
anyone to call the licensing API. The store
will check that the caller is authorized to
make a licensing API check for a given app.
In this way we provide separation among the
licensing data for various apps.
The developer that creates a web app in the
Chrome Web Store is the only user with permission
to call the licencing API for that app.
In order to securely authenticate the owner
of an application, we use OAuth access tokens.
These tokens prove that you have the right
to call the API.
We automatically provide you with an OAuth
access token in the developer dashboard for
each app you own. An OAuth access token is
really a token and a token secret, but I just
refer to them as an access token.
To create a token, go to the developer dashboard
and follow the link labeled “AuthToken”.
The next page explains what you need the token
for and at the bottom of the page, you will
see a button to generate the OAuth access
token.
When you click that button you will see the
values for oauth_token and oauth_token_secret
fill in.
Those tokens are scoped so they will only
work to access the Chrome Web Store licensing
API and cannot be used to access other information
from Google.
Please note that the Chrome Web Store will
not display these values more than one time
for security reasons, so, don’t forget to
copy them to a secure location before you
leave the page. If necessary, you can return
later to generate a new access token.
Now you should have all the data you need
to call the licensing API:
An OAuth access token
A User ID
and an App ID.
Let’s look at the details of calling the
API using HTTP.
The licensing API endpoint is simply a URL
containing the app ID and the user ID. The
app and user IDs must be URL-encoded.
To call the licensing API, you need to add
OAuth signature parameters. You can use an
OAuth library to sign the HTTP requests.
Visit http://code.google.com/apis/gdata/docs/client-libraries.html
for a list of libraries that may be used to
perform these API calls in various web development
languages.
The signing step needs the following pieces
of data:
The consumer key: This is always “anonymous”.
The consumer secret: This is also always “anonymous”.
The token and the token secret.
The consumer key and consumer secret are anonymous
because you, the developer, are granting access
to the application you own.
JSON is the default response format for API
requests. This response will indicate whether
the user should be granted permission to use
your app.
If you prefer the ATOM format, you can specify
alt=atom in the URL.
To learn more about the Chrome Web Store and
how to integrate with our licensing API, just
visit code.google.com/chrome/webstore.